can you convince the listeners why your
boy Kobe coming to why he deserves this
title shot well Hall definitely deserves
it Muhammad has it has done enough I
think
I think stopped Leon's win streak he
doesn't have to say beat him he didn't
beat him but he did stop the win streak
as far as head to head Colby versus
Muhammad rankings do matter and rankings
aren't Fair the rankings committee has
put Colby in front of Muhammad
ultimately that is going to matter and
when you have kobami Kobe was an interim
Champion he never lost and one day woke
up and wasn't interim Champion like this
isn't a riddle that happened to him yeah
Colby fought and defeated the BMF
Champion but there was every day that
Colby woke up and he was the BMF
Champion he's always been ranked in
front he's been the clearest number one
contender in our sport he can't fight
for the belt because he already did
twice it's a really unique situation I
do think like if vulcanovsky left the
weight class just by example he leaves
or it gets me obviously Max is going to
go in he showed a gap between himself
and everybody else I do think that Kobe
is the right move